Meinen Leute, euer Karl Leuterbach am Start und jetzt so die Pandemie, also wo sie so gut wie vorbei ist, kann ich mich jetzt auch endlich mal zurücklehnen und mir meinen Lieblingspodcast, das Podcast Ufo mit Stefan Titzer und Florentin Willrein pfeffern.
Ach so, ich weiß nicht, was ich mir ehemalige.
So viele Fragen jetzt, ich habe so viele Fragen, sorry, bevor wir euch gleich begrüssen, ich sehe euch. Ihr seht, ihr sitzt da mit grossen Augen und noch grösseren Ohren, wollt mir, Stefan Thielse und dir, meinem lieben Florentin Will, zuhören, was wir jetzt reden haben. Trotz Verwirrung werden die Vornamen genannt. Das ist drin. Um die Frage zu aus dem Weg zu räumen. Selbst wenn du auf einem Berghang von der Lawine erfasst werden würdest, würdest du das in der Panik noch abmoderieren. Ich würde sagen, das war es von mir, Stefan Tietze, vielen Dank für alles. Die Stimme, die ihr gehört habt, war Florentin Will, macht's gut, nächste Woche, wie ihr heben habt. Nächste Woche nichts, weil hier kommt eine Lawine auf mich zu und ich sag schon mal viel Spaß mit Gessl ist die Geistverband. Aber das ist so drin, selbst wenn jemand mit einem Messer auf dich zulaufen würde, kurz davor, wenn dich zu erstrecken, würde sagen, so, gut, das war's von uns, viel Spaß bei der nächsten Folge. Machst du das abends nicht im Bett? Na klar, das war's von mir heute, mein Name ist Stefan Tietze, schau doch morgen wieder da ein, wenn's um 10 Uhr geht's los. Ja, freut euch, morgen um 10 Uhr geht's direkt los, kann ein bisschen später sein, aber es erscheint auf jeden Fall ein, das wird ein richtig guter Tag. Und dann geht der Wecker los und dann, hi, mein Name ist Stefan Tietze, ich freue mich sehr viel. Drei, zwei, eins. Hey, hallo und herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Das ganze Leben ist eine Moderation im Grunde. Schatz, Schatz, halt einmal die Fresse, halt einmal deine Fresse. Das ist das Level, auf dem sie einsteigen. Ja, um zehn Uhr morgens. Schatz, halt einmal kurz deine Fresse. Sie hat es noch nie angesprochen, dass es ein Thema ist, aber dann steigt sie so ein, wo ich denke, sie hätte es vorher ansprechen müssen, dass es nicht gefällt. Sie sagen können, kannst du aufhören, aber dass sie direkt anfangen mit, hey Schatz, kannst du bitte die Fresse halten. Ja, das ist der grösste Fehler bei Streits, ist, dass man zu hoch einsteigt. Du musst dir selber Raum geben zum Eskalieren. Wenn du ganz oben einsteigst, hast du keine Chance mehr. Du musst wirklich rampen, hoch rampen, ganz wichtig. Ramp dich up, ramp you up, da heißt auch die Folge. Ramp it up. Wirklich, die Folge heißt so Ramp it up. Bitte nicht, bitte nicht.
Ramp it up.
Nicht zeitig am Boden.
Vielen Dank an Karl für das Intro, der uns das zugeschickt hat.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Ein paar Fragen.
Kann man jetzt, ist das so ein Deepfake-Scheiss?
Oh.
Ja.
Es klang schon genauso, ehrlich gesagt.
Ein KI-neuronales Netzwerk-die Zukunft. Dinge, die ich nicht verstehe. Aber ich kann sie benennen, ich kann Dinge sagen. Wie man auch die Illusion direkt kaputt macht, wenn man einsteigen will. Was ist so ein neuronales Netzwerk-Scheiss? Oder hat Karl-Aude auch jetzt... Man weiß nichts mehr in dieser unsicheren Welt, in dieser unsicheren Zeit. Ja? Ja. Was meinst du, wie viele von deinen Aussagen mittlerweile schon im Umlauf sind? Sagt, ich habe Stefan Tietze auf einer Party getroffen und dann so. Mein Name ist Stefan Tietze und vielen Dank an Robert, den ich gerade getroffen habe in der Party. Entschuldigung, ich muss kurz an die Bar einen Rink holen, bitte verzeih mir. Danke, thank you. Thank you. Fremdsprache kommt ganz schlecht. By the way I'm a computer. By the way I'm a computer. Aber wie ist es, wenn man eine KI fragt, bist du ein Computer? By the way I'm a computer. Müssten die das sagen? Just to get it out of the way, I'm a computer. But we can still have... Aber ist das so wie bei Undercover-Polizisten, wenn man sie fragt? Ich muss die Wahrheit sagen. By the way, I'm a computer. Bei IBM. Okay, also das musst du sagen. Ich muss das sagen. Alles klar. Gibt es da Computergesetze oder Rechte, an die du dich halten musst? Ja, Wikipedia ist das ganz klar vor. Okay, wunderbar. Ist doch gut, dass eine gewisse Ehrlichkeit dabei ist. Ich bin ein Computer. Nicht, dass du das übergisst. Okay, nee, das glaube ich ist klar. Ich glaube, das ist noch so zehn Jahre lang recht klar. Aber gut, dass du sagst. Ich bin Menschen zum Verwechseln ähnlich, deswegen muss ich sagen, was ich bin. Ich glaube, du kannst den Teil streichen. Also ich glaube, im Ernst, du musst gar nicht unbedingt immer sagen, dass du Computer bist. Ich glaube, du hast nicht ganz verstanden, dass ich ein Computer bin. Doch, doch, das glaube ich ist aber nett, nett von dir. Danke, danke. Freut mich, deine Bekanntschaft zu machen, Florian Tübingen. Wie so bei so Playstation 1 Spielen, wo so ein Disclaimer kommt, these are not real images. These stunts are done by pixels. Macht es nicht im echten Leben. Das war so lustig, bei GTA Vice City, was wirklich noch ein Pixelgewitter ist, ich weiß, ich weiß, schon ganz toll für die Zeit und man verklärt das aber ein bisschen.
Niemand widerspricht dir schon.
Naja, ich höre schon diese Masse.
Du musst gegen niemanden wehren.
Was?
So ein Zeitverzögert kommt so eine Welle.
Okay, aber fehlt uns, weil sie nicht wissen, wo unser Studio ist.
Ja, mehrfach.
Ist noch ein Pixelgewitter und da haben mir meine Eltern verboten, grundlos in Menschenmassen reinzufahren.
Aha, aber mit Grund schon. Welchen Grund gab es? Also was waren die drei Gründe, die bei dir im Haushalt anerkannt waren, dass man sagt, gut, unter den Bedingungen muss man quasi in eine Menschenmenge fahren? Es ist eine Quest und ich komme nur so weiter.
Ja.
Dann wäre es erlaubt, die Menschenmasse schreit,
9-11 was an Inside-Job.
Okay, ja, dann rein. Solche Sachen, also viele Verschwörungstheorien. Und wenn es einfach kurz und an Sonntag. Und da habe ich auch schon gedacht, was glaubt ihr denn, dass dieses Spiel auch nur ansatzweise die Realität vermittelt, oder dass man das verwechseln könnte, oder was auch immer. ich nicht verstanden, diese Videospiel-Thematik, aber bei ... ich verstehe es jetzt noch eher, weil es naheliegender ist. Bei Escape from Tarkov sieht fucking realistisch aus. Zum Glück wurde diese Killerspiel-Debatte zu einem Zeitpunkt geführt, wo man noch ganz einfach sagt, da hast du eigentlich einen kompletten Schaden. Das ist doch kein echter Mensch. Mittlerweile ist sie zum Glück abgeschlossen, abgehakt, sodass alle sich darauf rückrufen können. Ich habe ein bisschen Angst vor dem Ersten, der wieder sagt, wir haben das Thema auf den Tisch gebracht. Weil jetzt sieht es halt wirklich echt aus, photorealistisch aus. Naja, vielleicht lachen wir in 20 Jahren genauso wieder drüber. Aber ich habe ohnehin nie GTA gespielt, weil ich hatte einen Gamecube. Ich hatte den Nintendo Gamecube mit dem süssen Pixel-Pigman und dem süssen Mario. Da gab es aber auch sowas wie GTA, nämlich True Crime Streets of LA. Und die Idee war, du bist da der Polizist. Aber es zeichnet sich auch da wieder ab, dass Gamecube so die kleine, süße Variante ist. Ja. Von der Big-Boy-Playstation, der Get Your Girls in Safety. Ich bin hier der krasse Motherfucker, ich bin zwölf Jahre alt, habe eine Playstation, und du warst der mit dem Gamecube, der süße kleine Nintendo-Mann, nicht? Und das Interessante im Spiel war, du hattest so einen Counter-Good-Cop, Bad-Cop, und du musstest immer zu irgendwohin, wo Verbrechen war, und dann konntest du es auf die Good-Cop-Art lösen oder auf die oder auf die Bad Cop Art lösen. Und zum Beispiel gab es dann so, das klassische Verbrechen war Ruhestörung. Ein Ehepaar streitet sich auf der Strasse. Der Good Cop Ansatz war, du fährst hin, du steigst hin, redest mit den Leuten und klärst das Ganze. Bad Cop Ansatz war, du fährst mit 120 kmh über die Beine drüber. Nein, nein, wirklich, das war, sorry, ich wollte nicht die Pointe klauen, weil ich nicht dachte, das ist ernst. Doch, absolut, immer Auftrag gelöst, Bad Cop-Punkte plus fünf, ist einfach, und es war immer so, jedes Verbrechen lässt sich einfach mit reiner PS-Pferdestärke lösen, einfach, du fährst einfach drüber. Und so
habe ich die Verbrechen gelöst. War ein tolles Spiel, aber
natürlich war ich immer ein bisschen neidisch
auf alle, die GTA spielen konnten.
Und ich hatte immer die
Sagt man im Englischen auch PS? Nein.
Hat mir gar keinen Sinn. Horsepower.
HP. HP?
Ich weiß nicht, ob man
Health Points.
Mein Auto, mein Mercedes hat 130 HP. Oh Oh wirklich? Braucht er ein Medipack? Wir sind Gamer! Gamer! Gamer! Wir lieben das Spielen, wir sind Gamer! An nem schönen Sonntag hab ich mein Gamecube in der Hand, und mein Freund ist am Start, und wir reichen uns die Hand, denn wir spielen Good Cop, Bad Cop, wir sind zwölf und haben die beste Zeit und bald werden wir dreizehn. Ich würde auch lieber GTA spielen. War eine tolle Zeit, oder? Videogames? Als wäre es jetzt vorbei, als wären wir jetzt aus dem Alter raus. Naja, also ich versuche, also ich befasse mich jetzt auch schon mit anderen Dingen. Also ich lese Zeitungen jeden Morgen, stecke mir die Pfeife an, mache mir ein schönes Glas Asbest oder Wismut. Absinnt meinst du vielleicht? Ja, genau, Absinth und steck mir, also mach mir einen schönen Topf Wald, Wald, Wald, Wolfram und dann wird das Genossen. Sir, Sie hatten Wolfram bestellt, Topf Wolfram. Ja genau, für ein Frühstück. Ich habe in der Küche nachgefragt und wir wissen nicht genau, was das ist. Was? Gertrud, hör dir das mal an. Was ist das für eine Küche, die haben keinen Wolfram in der Küche. Ich könnte ihnen stattdessen einfach irgendwie ein Gulasch anbieten oder so. Ich bitte dich, Gulasch, Kinderfraas. Schauen Sie mich mal an. Ich habe einen Anzug an, ich habe einen Schal an, ich habe Handschuhe an. Ihre Pfeife und ihre Handschuhe suggerieren, dass sie sehr alt sind und sehr weise und auch noch ein Verbrechen planen oder lösen. Wie dem auch sei, wir wissen nicht genau, was das ist und würden Ihnen stattdessen auch Königsberger Klopse anbieten oder Fischstäbchen.
Nee, geben Sie mir mal so einen schönen Hammelhahn oder sowas. Wie heisst diese Vögel?
Frau schüttelt mit dem Kopf. Frau will aus dem Gespräch heraus. Oder wir können Ihnen auch Fischstäbchen anbieten oder irgendwie Chicken McNuggets oder so einen Pinocchio-Teller. Das ist schon lecker. Er tappt! Ja, okay, dann vergess nicht, Wolfram, ich nimm Kaba. Ja, okay, Sie kriegen Kaba. Das ist auch so gut, dass es nochmal ein extra Kinderwort gibt für Kaba. Und Kinderkanal, Kika. Alles ist so na na na. Zwei Silben, zwei Vokale, die auseinander streben. Das ist wirklich der Punkt, wo du erwachsen bist. Wenn du sagst, ich rühre mir jetzt einen richtig schönen Kakao an. Und es ist alles im Raum so. Ist Kaba Kakao? Ja, klar. Wo steht denn Kaba? Kaba?
Kakao-Basisches Milch. Ein Kakao-Basisches
Erfrischungsgetränk.
Ja, abgekürzt.
Kaba-Ege.
Kaba-Ege, ein Kakao-basiertes
Erfrischungsgetränk.
Aber abgekürzt Kaba.
Kakao-basiert. Ist Kaba die Abkürzung, oder?
Nee. Kaba steht Ich glaube, es ist wirklich einfach nur diese Infantensprache. Dass du einfach hier kommen die Infanten, dann sagst du einfach statt Kakao ... Hier kommen die Infanten, wir kommen genau. Kommt ihr in Frieden, das müsste ich jetzt wissen. Wir wollen nur was Leckeres trinken, dann sind wir zufrieden. Ihr bekommt Zweckhaber hier, bitteschön, und jetzt lasst uns in Ruhe. Und dann wie Kinder so extrem viel trinken. Einfach so weg, und dann wieder wegrennen, wegrennen. Alles muss schnell funktionieren, alles ist auf Zack, das Leben, es ist so viel zu entdecken, wir müssen aufholen. Ja, es gibt so viel. Wo war ich die letzten 40 Jahre und dann kommt man auf die Erde und denkt erstmal. Genau, ich muss nachholen. Oder das Kind hängt halt im Mutterleib und denkt sich, Leute, komm, ich muss gib mir das Go! Gib mir das Go!
Ich bin am Start!
Gib mir, komm!
Ich war nicht am Start, es gibt nämlich dann, jetzt habe ich auf dem VHS... Von deiner Geburt?
Ja, ja, nee, nicht von meiner Geburt, aber ich glaube, vier Tage danach
kam ja mein Onkel mit der Kamera rein und ich war vier Tage auf der Welt und meine ganze
Gestik, also ich habe meine, die ganze Zeit so diese, können alle die Fresse halten, Falten im Gesicht, also so oben so diese beiden Falten, die man hat, wenn man denkt, was ist das gerade dein Problem, könnt ihr alle verkatert, also könnt ihr einfach mal kurz leise sein, viel leiser sein, bitte, bitte leise, leise, so habe ich dieses und ich bin vier Tage auf der Welt und schon überdrüssig und meine ganze Gestik gesagt, ach. Ja, du kannst auch nicht kommunizieren, es ist nur so ein einfaches Leiden, so, ach komm, nee, Leute, bitte, die Geschichte hast du schon, du hast ja zum hundertsten Mal erzählt, wie die Geburt lief, komm, ein bisschen Piano, bitte. Vor allem, meine Tante ist dann da und erzählt eine Geschichte und mein Gesicht sagt, diese ist so boring, diese Geschichte, ist die erste Geschichte, die ich höre auf der Welt. Ich habe meine Tante noch nie gesehen und meine Reaktion ist Rapid. Ja, ist das jetzt so wichtig, dieses Detail, dass Onkel Odi dabei war? Onkel Odi. Onkel Odi. Dass Onkel Odi mit Loki dabei war. Ist das ein Gott oder was? Halt die Fresse hier. Boah, bin ich der spannendste Mensch der Welt, da ist mir alles zu viel. Aber ja, das ist auch völlig okay. Man muss nicht immer glücklich sein. Ja, das stimmt. Auch nicht, wenn man, weißt du, auf Babys liegt da auch so viel Druck. Ja, aber ich glaube, es ist dann natürlich, ich mag es auch, wenn alte Leute wieder in diesen mir ist alles scheißegal Modus gehen. Zum Beispiel hier unten, wenn ich es immer gut, die Tür, jemand macht die Tür auf. Hier in unserem Bürokomplex. In unserem riesigen Industriekomplex, in unserem Titzel Studios, 40-stöckiger Wolkenkratzer. Und unten geht die Tür so auf, jemand macht es mir auf, ich gehe durch, durch die offene Tür und sag noch so im Vorbeigehen so Dankeschön und der einfach direkt nach vorne, komplett ignoriert, nichts einfach, marschiert an mir vorbei. Ich finde nichts Schöneres als ignorierte Grüße. Ich liebe das, das ist so ein Vakuum, so ein Guten Morgen! Aber man ist immer lieber am ignorierten End, oder nicht am ignorierenden End, weil, total. Man will schon ignoriert werden, weil alles, ich finde das selber sehr, ich grüße immer zurück. Aber diese Stelle immer so dieses Guten Morgen! Ja, gut, dann nicht. Ich habe immer bei, wenn ich mal wieder in meine Heimat fahre und dann Dachbarn auf der Strasse sehe und die brauchen immer zu lange, um zu checken, dass ich da auch sehr lange gewohnt habe und da aufgewachsen bin. Sie erkennen mich dann oft nicht wieder und sowas. Und dann fahr ich, dann winkt, und der Strasse ist üblich, typische Kleinstadt, die Vorortsiedlung, wo man dann natürlich sich grüsst die ganze Zeit. Und dann fahr ich da rein und die grüsst immer alle super freundlich, aber sie grüssen nie zurück, weil es sind immer so, die brauchen einen Tick zu lang, eine Müh zu lang, um mich wiederzuerkennen, um diese Skepsis abzulegen, wer fährt da mit einem fremden Auto in unsere Strasse rein und so und dadurch fährt ich durch die Strasse winkend wie in so einem superschönen bunten Astronauten, die ankommen. Genau, oder so einen Rom-Com-Film, so alles superschön und alles übersättigt und total toll und die Nachbarn grüssen mich alle nicht zurück und ich finde es auch irgendwie, das ist immer ein gutes Gefühl, das ist einfach lustig. Das ist bei mir auch immer ein Lacher, ich grüsse auch jeden Hund, immer die Situation, wenn so ein Hund angebunden ist vor dem Supermarkt, alleine, wenn er mal so privat, genau, so Abend, Malzeit, der Herr, Malzeit, nichts zurück, aber immer nur so dieser dieser awkward Blick einfach so, weil ich finde, da haben Hunde
mal so, das ist vielleicht der einzige Moment, wo Hunde
wirklich privat mal kurz eine
Raucherpause haben, wo die kurz eine Pause haben,
weil immer wenn die mit ihrem Menschen sind, müssen sie
bewachen, beschützen, was will der
jetzt von mir und dann diese kurze
Pause, wo man mal wirklich so ein
Morgen,
ich habe mal gehört, dass Blindenhunde
und auch Polizeihunde
sehr wohl checken, wann sie nicht
gebraucht werden und sind dann umso, sind dann sehr gut
Vielen Dank. Ja, morgen. Ich habe mal gehört, dass Blindenhunde und auch Polizeihunde sehr wohl checken, wann sie nicht gebraucht werden und sind dann umso, das sind dann sehr gut erzogene Hunde und die checken dann aber genau, dass sie wie frei haben, wenn zum Beispiel nicht der blinde Besitzer oder die Besitzerin auf sie dann aufpasst und sowas, dann wenn sie woanders sind, wo sie dann nicht diese Rolle spielen müssen oder auch wenn Polizeihunde außer Dienst sind, dann flippen die aus. Das sind oft sehr kindliche, übersteuerte Hunde. Einfach weil sie checken, weil sie das überkompensieren, weil sie checken, es ist alles möglich. Und das finde ich so süß, dass sie so oft dann im Job sind und sich so zurückhalten, aber dann, wenn sie frei sind, alle Dämme brechen. Das ist schon verrückt, dass die einfach einen Job haben, dass sie wirklich auch so eine andere Persona haben. Aber ihre Existenz ist der Job. Die Work-Life-Balance ist denkbar unausgeglichen bei Polizeihunden, findest du nicht? Ja, gut, bei Polizeihunden vielleicht nicht, aber bei Blindenhunden. Ich glaube, manche Hunde gehen auch so sehr in ihrem Job auf, dass sie gar nichts anfangen zu wissen mit sich selber, also dass sie mit der Freizeit gar nicht klarkommen. Klar, man legt sich aufs Couch, man macht Scrubs an und so, man weiss jetzt, ich sollte das jetzt genießen, aber man denkt sich immer, wo ist mein Herrchen? Schatz, Rex, Rex, mein Schatz, du nimmst die Arbeit zu oft mit nach Hause.
Ja, aber wo ist mein Herrchen jetzt? Der kann nicht sehen, was ist, wenn der sich in den falschen Bus setzt oder so?
Es ist doch alles gut, okay?
Ich ruf ihn noch mal an.
Dein Herrchen ruf ihn nicht noch mal an. Nein, gib mir mal das Handy jetzt. Nein, hör auf, jetzt bitte. So, jetzt legen wir mal beiseite. Du musst dich auch mal auf dich konzentrieren. Ich hätte schon lange nichts mehr von meinem kleinen Rex. Ja, aber du weisst, er ist auf mich angewiesen. Du nimmst immer die Arbeit. Ich weiss, dass Herbert auf dich angewiesen ist, okay? Ja, du hast ja recht. Du passt gut auf ihn auf, aber er ist gerade nicht hier. Er ist gerade im Urlaub mit seinen Verwandten, er hat eine gute Zeit. Er will auch, dass du dich mal freust, dass du mal du selbst bist. Aber immer nur blinden und blinden und blinden und das ist mein Job, das ist mein Job, das ist mein Job, ich kann sehen, ich kann sehen, ich kann sehen. Es ist fast aufdringlich, dass du Leuten immer von deinen funktionierenden Sinnen erzählst. Ja, ich meine, ich kann gut riechen, sehen. Ja, aber du hast recht, ich versuche, mich zu entspannen. Was wollen wir denn machen? Keine Ahnung, ich finde es schön... Was machst du denn so den ganzen... weil du hast ja... du hast jetzt schon länger keinen Job. Ich lauf bellen... naja, ich bin ein Hund in erster Linie. Na gut, aber... Was macht man bei meinem Job? Ich meine, wir streicheln mich und lächeln... Du hattest doch den Job, wo du hier gelernt hast, wie du auf dem Boden rumrollst. Das war doch gut. Das war doch ein guter Gig. Das ist kein Job, das ist mein, das ist kein Gig, das ist mein Leben, das mache ich gerne, das mache ich gerne, das mache ich gerne. Ja, aber was machst du den ganzen Tag so? Naja, also wenn ein Tennisball fliegt, dann hole ich den gern zurück. Für wen? Ich mache es mehr für mich, damit die es wieder werfen. Ja, aber also da verliert jemand sein Tennisball und du bringst ihn ihm zurück und hilfst ihm. Nein, sie werfen den, damit ich eine gute Zeit habe. Das ist doch kein Job. Ich brauche auch keinen Job. Ich bin ein Hund. Warum muss man, warum braucht man, ein Job definiert sich doch nicht. Du selbst definierst dich, dein Charakter definiert sich. Ich glaube, wir sind einfach zu anders. Wir sind zu unterschiedlich. Rex, als ich dich kennengelernt habe, warst du ein glücklicher, kleiner Schäferhund. Wir waren viel zu jung, als wir diese Romanze begonnen hatten. Ja, wir waren noch Welpen. Wir waren noch Welpen. Noch das Maul an der Mutter. Ja, ich glaube auch, wir sind Geschwister. Rückblickend glaube ich das auch. Wir sehen gleich aus. Du warst der einzige Welpe, den ich je getroffen habe, aber du meinst gerade, wir hingen an derselben Zitze.
Ich habe das geschickt im Schiff, dieses unangenehme Thema. Aber lass uns vielleicht noch mal, weil ich glaube, wir sind... Ja, ich glaube schon. Ist das ein Problem? Ja, ich glaube schon. Ey.
Ich glaube schon. Jetzt haben wir diese Wohnung gekauft und alles von meinem Geld.
Jetzt haben wir die alle eingerichtet von meinem Geld.
Und jetzt sitzen wir hier, ne?
Also technisch gesehen, also wenn, dann müsstest du halt gehen, weil eigentlich ist es, die Wohnung ist auf meinen Namen.
Wie das ging, habe ich mich auch noch gefragt.
Ja, dann, ne?
Kannst du kurz diesen Tennisball werfen?
Ich werfe ihn zur Tür raus. Ich laufe hinterher. Dann sind wir ja beide glücklich. Ciao Rex. Ciao Rexer. Das wäre ein Red Flag. Das hätte uns auffallen sollen. Ja, alle, ich habe mal gehört, alle Tiere haben den gleichen Buchstaben von einem Wurf. Mein Fuß schleift ein, weil ich meinen Schuh zu eng zugebunden habe. Was lohnt? Ich muss kurz das Problem lösen. Warum hast du deinen Schuh zu eng zugebunden? Ich weiß nicht. Du wolltest zu viel Kontrolle, habe ich das Gefühl. Vielleicht wollte ich was kompensieren. Ich habe zu wenig Kontrolle. Was anderes ist zu locker. Deswegen musst du jetzt deinen Fuss ... Sonst läuft gerade gar nichts. Dann habe ich gedacht, komm, machst du wenigstens deinen Schuh eng zu. Okay, alles klar. So, wir kommen zu einer witzigen Mail von ... Dann beweise ich mir selbst noch, dass ich ein bisschen Kontrolle über mein Leben habe. Ja, okay. Kommen wir zu den Hausaufgaben. Und zwar, witzig, wir haben... Witzig, haha, habt ihr alle was zu lachen, bei euch geht's allen gut. Und zwar schreibt Jonas, weil wir hatten ja mal das Thema Berufsorientierung. Ich meine... Alle Hüllen fallen einfach, alle... Ach. Bo das klingt ja wie ein Dämon in mir, der auch noch lacht. Es lacht immer jemand mit. Moment mal, bist du besessen? Ich glaube, ich bin ein bisschen besessen. Ja, nee, wir hatten eine Communityaktion. Nee, eigentlich nicht, sondern wir hatten vor langer Zeit mal drüber gesprochen zum Thema Berufsorientierung.
Deutschland braucht gewisse Berufe dringend, andere vielleicht nicht gar so dringend. Trotzdem entscheiden sich die Berufsberater dieser Nation, die jungen Schüler, die Lernen und Arbeitswilligen in eine merkwürdige Richtung zu lenken. Da haben wir schon viele interessante Beispiele gesehen. Jetzt meldet sich Jonas zu Wort. Und zwar schreibt Jonas, er hat in der 12. Klasse sechs Stunden lang einen Orientierungstest gemacht für die Berufswahl. Sechs Stunden lang. Also stell dir mal vor. Weil er desorientiert war? Oder weil das Gang und Gäbe war? Also ich meine, stell dir mal vor ... Weil er sehr desorientiert war? Oder weil das der Gang und Gelbe war, das so lange zu machen? Ich bin auch nicht gefunden.
Also stell dir mal vor, in der 12. Klasse bist du 17.
Stell dir mal vor, ich glaube, ich hätte mit 17 Jahren Probleme,
sechs Stunden zu füllen mit mir.
Weil ich meine, ich mag Warhammer, Warhammer 40k.
Früher habe ich halt Hell-der-Ringe-Tabletop gespielt.
Was sind so deine Unsicherheiten?
Naja, manchmal würfel ich nicht gut. Und ich diese Mäntel noch nicht so gut bemalen. Ja, du bist 17 Jahre alt, dein Leben kann in alle Richtungen gehen. Wir haben noch fünf Stunden, neunundfünfzig Mitarbeiter. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das füllen soll.
Du bist wie jeder andere siebten Jahre Junge.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich mit dir machen soll.
Studiere Wirtschaftsingenieurwesen.
Tschüss.
Okay.
Tschüss, Timmy.
Und nach sechs Stunden hat Jonas sein Urteil bekommen.
Nach sechs Stunden wurde er komplett durchleuchtet.
Jede Faser seines Charakters wurde einmal angezupft. Ich stelle mir so Kingsman-like Tests vor.
Er muss sich kurz hinlegen, schlafen, der Raum ist unter Wasser.
Genau, er muss Kopf über so eine Bombe entschärfen.
Genau, und Leute mit weissen Kitteln stehen hinter verspiegelten Fenstern und machen sich so Notizen dazu.
Reaktionstest, Assoziation, Baum.
Äh, Faum.
Nein, das müssen echte Wörter sein, Timmy. Ähm, Warhammer. Ähm, Schmutz. Lisa aus der 7C. Ähm, cool. Tina aus der 7C. Cool. Deine Mutter. Kalt. Okay. Da wurde viel aufgeschrieben, weil kalt sind die Stifte von den weissen Wissenschaftlern. Ja, da wurde der Spitzer mal rumgereicht. Von den weisskitteligen, gekittelten. Sechs Stunden lang wurde Jonas also durchleuchtet und danach kam das Urteil. Und zwar, es ist ja schwer, einen Menschen wirklich einzufangen, deswegen gab es zwei Vorschläge. Zwei Vorschläge, zwei mögliche Berufe, die zu Jonas passen würden.
Nach sechs Stunden. Erster Beruf, Estrich-Verleger. Das ist nicht mein ... und er auch so, das ist nicht ... Leute, das ist nicht mein Job. Ich meine, ich kann Estrich, weil ich kann auch ... Kann ich dann kein ... Nur mal so, hypothische Frage, kann ich dann auch Laminat verlegen? Was? Nein! Sind Sie wahnsinnig und dealen mit den Hobbys, mit denen Blutwerten, mit dem Blutzucker, bitte. Okay. Sie schreien Estrich, sie schreien Estrich. Also erste Priorität war Estrich Verleger und jetzt knapp auf dem zweiten Platz Model Berater. Model Berater, es gibt nichts Gemeineres, Model Berater. Also Model Ber Berater, ich kann ... Model, okay, Leute lehnen sich vor im Stuhl, Berater. Aber auch nicht Model Manager oder Agent, sondern Berater, Anwalt, Assistent. Aber ist auch so, sind Sie gerne in der Nähe von schönen Frauen? Habe ich zu schnell cool gesagt auf die Frage Lisa von 7c. Erklären Sie Frauen gerne Dinge? Ja. Na dann sind Sie Modelberater. Eins zu eins. Aber fantastisch. Erstmal, es gibt eine ganz kleine Schnittmenge zwischen den tausenden Estrich-Verlegern auf der Welt und den tausenden Model-Beratern auf der Welt. Jonas ist genau die Mitte. Allein, dass diese beiden Berufe so nah aneinander glaubt man ja gar nicht. Aber war das ein knappes Rennen? War es eine knappe Kiste? Es scheint war es ein sehr knappes Rennen. Estrich-Verleger hat es noch auf eins geschafft, aber zwei Model-Berater. Aber gibt es da so Prozentzahlen, also so wie Estrich-Verleger, 89 Prozent Model-Berater?
Schreibt er nicht.
Es waren nur die beiden besten.
Aber ich kann ja verstehen, wenn jemand sagt, hey, Estrich-Verleger wäre was. Ja. Und du bist 17, dann sagst du, okay, ich mache eine Ausbildung irgendwie in einem Betrieb oder so, okay. Aber wenn jemand sagt Modelberater, wie sollst du als 17-Jähriger, also gibt es da in IHK geprüften Modelberater, gibt es da Modelberater für Dummies, was du dir dann aus der Bibliothek holst? Was ist das denn für ein Job überhaupt? Also vor allem Modelberater. Ja, das ist so spezifisch merkwürdig und auch also dass ich wirklich glaube, okay, am Tag davor kamen, hallo, wir sind die Agenten und Modelberater, Walk that way, Inc. Walk our way. Walk our way, Inc. Und wir wollten, hier sind 10 Millionen Dollar. Oh wow, Sie brauchen so dringend Leute? Oh, wir brauchen dringend neue Leute.
Wie viele denn?
Einen.
Einen?
Ja, erstmal nur einen.
Okay.
Ich suche Ihnen den besten Modelberater aus. Ja, können Sie das machen?
Hören Sie zu, weil uns wurde neulich jemand geschickt und da hat sich herausgestellt, der ist eher so ein Estrich-Verleger.
Oh, okay.
Und es hat nicht gepasst.
Ich meine, der Boden ist wunderschön, die Agentur sieht wunderschön aus.
Mehr Informationen auf www. Oh, okay.
Und es hat nicht gepasst. Ich meine, der Boden ist wunderschön, die Agentur sieht wunderschön aus.
Ich verstehe, das ist eine, ja, ja.
Aber es ist halt nicht das, was wir suchen. Also wir suchen primär jemanden, der unsere Models berät.
Ja, ja.
Gute Tipps gibt.
Okay.
Halt berät.
Ja, nee, klar, ich verstehe total. Also, müssen Sie mir nicht erklären. Selbst erklären.
Müssen Sie mir nicht erklären. Machen wir. Aber ich weiß nicht, Jonas schreibt, bis heute überlegt er noch einen Job zu machen, der die beiden Fähigkeiten vereint, also beides zu machen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er als Roteberater arbeitet.
Aber wie lustig wäre jetzt, wenn die Nachricht endet mit, ja und ich lege seitdem Estrich und es ist mein Traumjob und die haben Recht, weil das klingt ja, wenn man diese Art Tipps gibt, weil ich habe es immer für Humbug gehalten und ich habe immer noch jetzt hier ein kleines Realismus-Fragezeichen möchte ich trotzdem noch stellen, weil Dinge erzählt man dann gerne, glaubt man dann ja auch irgendwann selber und man erzählt sie ein bisschen überspitzt nach.
Weil ich musste auch häufig lachen über die spezifischen Tipps von diesen Berufsinformationszentren, aber ja, weil ich, dann scheint es ja wirklich, sie scheinen sich ihrer Sache sehr sicher zu sein, weil je spezifischer, desto mehr stellt man sich ja die Frage, wie kriegt ihr das raus und was sind eure Hintergedanken da? Ich meine, nach sechs Stunden wäre ich jetzt auch irgendwie irritiert, wenn da einfach nur rauskäme Polizist. Das muss schon wirklich was super, also Zollbeamter. So, du kannst nicht sechs Stunden jemanden durchleuchten und dann sagen, du bist Handwerker, sondern da muss dann schon Estrichverleger genau drinstehen. So, das funktioniert nicht. Aber ich finde allein Modelberater fantastisch. Modelberater. Sag mal du hier, Verena, es gibt da ein ganz neues heißes Produkt. So ein Plastikstäbchen, das schiebst du dir ins Ohr und das saugt dann so den Ohrenschmalz raus. Also das ist Ohrmax, das saugt wirklich und die bräuchten und ich glaube, das wäre ein geiler Job für dich. Aber da müsste ich dafür ja die Cartier-Kampagne absagen. Genau, aber du hast ein, nee, denk mal langfristig. Ich soll mal langfristig lenken? Denk mal langfristig, sei mal nicht, sei mal, sei mal, schau mal nach vorne. Okay, ich meine, du bist Modelberater. Wir müssen aus deinen Ohren mehr rausholen. Sprich, also direkt, wir müssen da mehr rausholen. Dankeschön, aber ich glaube, du sagst immer, du bist so fokussiert auf meine Ohren. Ja, weil ich glaube, das ist dein grösstes Kapital. Ohren, Alter nicht. Denk dran, Verena, Ohren, Alter nicht. Ohren, Alter nicht. Und wenn dir da gibt es Ohren, Alter nicht. Denk mal dran, was wir da alles machen können. DM, Wattestäbchen, Brillenmodel. Mit Ohren kann man so viel machen. Aber Katikathie bietet mir auch eine Menge Geld jetzt und so. Machst du das für Geld? Machst du das für Geld? Ehrlich gesagt. Bist du Model für Geld? Ja, schon. So habe ich dich nicht beraten, Verena. Ich weiss, du bist. Mach das, mach das mit dem Ohrenschmalz, das ist prestigerecht, das ist gut, mach das. Das macht 40 Euro übrigens. 40 Euro? Das geht voll klar, ehrlich gesagt. Okay. Und du, pass mal auf, was hast du für einen Fussboden zu Hause? Laminat. Okay, gut, dass du sagst. Aber ich suche mir nach was Neuem frisch. Genau, weil ich habe Kofferraum voller Estrich. Und ich kann nicht direkt nach Hause fahren. Draußen, dein Van. Der Van, Estrich und Modelberatung, Marquardt. Das wäre ein Van, wo ich so double-taken würde. Ja, wo ich warten würde, bis der Besitzer kommt. Oben Anzug, unten so diese typische Handwerker. Ich habe sehr viele Taschen für Utensilien, Reisverschlüsse, diese Handwerkerhose, diese schwarze Korthose und oben einfach ein schicker Anzug drüber. Estrich Verleger und Model Beratung, Marquardt. Entschuldigung, beraten Sie auch zu Estrich? Nein, aber ich kann an guten Kollegen verweisen. Estrich-Beratung und Model-Verleger. Oh, das klang. Oh, oh. Das war viel. Au. Sorry, das war nicht Podcast-Uvo angemessen. Das möchte ich gerne zurück. Wir ziehen diesen Zotting-Witz gerne zurück. Wir lassen ihn kurz noch da stehen. Sorry. Sorry. Nee, aber was du gerade so weggelacht hast, es stimmt ja nicht ganz. Wir hatten letzte Woche nämlich einen Aufruf an unsere werten Hörerinnen und Hörer. Weil du dich an den Aufruf erinnerst, oder wie? Weil ich mich daran erinnerte, wir wollten nämlich von euch wissen. Was sind Gesten? Du bist an meinem Schieber. Willst du mich leiser machen, weil ich jetzt zu doll schreie? Florentin, Florentin, das ist alles, was ich habe, ist in diesem Podcast diese Stimme. Wir hatten nämlich den Aufruf, welche Gesten gab es mal, die es nicht mehr gibt. Gab es früher spannende Gesten, die man gemacht hat? Klopf auf Holz. Genau, aber welche, die eingeschlafen sind, aber coole Sachen, die wir vielleicht wieder zurückholen, aber die gibt es ja alle noch. Heavy Metal. Da kam nichts, da kam gar nichts, niemand hat uns geschrieben.
Und ich finde es auch okay.
Mir hat einer in der U-Bahn zugerufen, wenn es irgendwann kein Bargeld mehr gibt, dann ist diese, ich haue die Fuffis in den Club, Big Spender-Geste, wenn man so mit der einen Handfläche über die andere Handfläche reibt. Hört auf, lohnt ihn in Zügen anzuschreien, vor allem wenn ihr im Ruhrbereich sitzt. Genau, das wäre sehr, sehr nett. Und zweitens, ja, noch gibt es Bargeld. Wir müssen uns ja noch diese 14 Monate kämpfen, in die es dieses verdammte Bargeld gibt. Und danach stimmt, kann es sein, dass diese, diese, wie kann man die beschreiben, so diese, diese Fuffis-Geste. Die eine Hand schmeißt die Fuffis in den Club, genau. Aber schmeißt die so wie eine, wie diese Maschinen funktionieren, mit denen man Trikots, Shirts in Publikum schießt. Ja, diese vollautomatischen Geldnoten. Ja, genau, Pistolen. Kartauen, diese Haubitzen, die Geldhaubitzen. Die Geldhaubitzen, hier steht schon was. Mein. Da kam gar nichts, aber dann hat Hollabere auf unserem schönen Subreddit geschrieben, lieber Herr Tietze, lieber Herr Will. Leider konnte ich meine Hausaufgaben zu Gesten, die keiner mehr macht, UFO 345 Schlauch, nicht erfüllen, da ich keine Gesten mehr gefunden habe. Sie sind wohl ausgestorben, genau wie die Dinosaurier und 150 Pflanzen und Tierarten pro Tag. Ui. Ja, weiter? Deshalb möchte ich gerne meine Alternativhausaufgabe einreichen. Das finden wir gut. Das finden wir nicht schlecht. Naja, woher wissen wir, dass sie nicht die Hausaufgabe schon unabhängig von unserem Aufruf gemacht hat? Weil sie das studiert. So wie das manchmal bei den Intros ist, wo wir das Gefühl haben, dass ihr uns einfach eure Songs schickt, die ihr eh schon gemacht habt, die nichts mit dem Podcast-Ufo zu tun haben und viel zu lang sind für Intros. Und dann tut ihr so, als hättet ihr das für uns gemacht. Kann das sein, dass ihr da für... Stefan! Also, deshalb möchte ich gerne mal alternativ. Jesus fucking Christ, Stefan, reiss dich zusammen. Du funktionierst nicht, du bist niemand, du kannst gar nichts. Du bindest deine Schuhe zu doll zu, du verblutest deine Inneninnerlich, weil du dir deine Schuhe zu eng zu bindest.
Du kannst nichts, du bist ein Loser.
Dreiss dich zusammen.
Deshalb möchte ich gerne eine Alternativhausaufgabe einreichen. Sprüche, die keiner mehr verwendet, weil sie preussische Sprichwörter von 1865 sind. Oh, say, can you see?
Oh, sag, kannst du sehen?
Tu zu dem Dimmerung.
Also, get the idea.
Erste Idee.
Erster Spruch.
Einen trockenen Aal geben.
Jetzt alle?
Einen trockenen Aal geben. Einen trockenen Aal geben. Jetzt alle? Einen trockenen Aal geben. Ihm mit dem Stock Prügel geben. Ihm den Aal. Weil der trockene Aal ist. Ist Harris hart. Ja. Er ist zum Abdruckreif. Er ist zum Abdruckreif. Seine Sterbeurkunde ist nahe. Ja. Da gibt es auch, glaube ich, viele. Abkratzen, ins Gras beißen, sowas in der Richtung. Er ist zum Abdruckereif. Aber dieses E, das macht es so anachronistisch. Er ist zum Abdruckereif. Dieses verdammte E. Kann da mal jemand einen Roman schreiben über das verschollene E, dass irgendjemand gesagt hat, Vorsicht vor dem Hund.
Und alle so, what the, was meinst du?
Kannst du die Tür noch kurz zumachen?
Was?
Die Tür.
Die was?
Die Türe.
Ach, die Türe.
Ich frage unseren Chef, ob ich mich woanders hinsetzen kann. Also ich halte es nicht mehr aus, mit dir das Büro zu teilen. Warum? Alles an dir stösst mich ab. Sorry, dass ich da heute so rauskomme, aber es heißt Tür, okay? Aber wird dann dein Stuhle frei? Oh mein Gott. Vor der Lade. Vor der Lade, dauert eine Weile. Aber wie viel Zeit hat die Menschheit gespart durch dieses E? Also wie effizient wurde die Menschheit durch das Wegfallen von E? Ja, ja. Jetzt muss man sich mal die Chronisten fragen. Den russischen Adler machen. Chronistenberater brauchen wir jetzt mal jemanden. Den russischen Adler machen. Warte, warte, warte, du sagst es, ich rate, was es ist. Den russischen Adler machen. Den russischen Adler machen. Der russischen Adler. Dann haben wir den russischen Adler gemacht. Ich würde jetzt mal natürlich denken, so was wir den polnischen machen, früh gehen, der russische Adler haut ab oder sowas, irgendwo, irgendwo, entweder irgendwo unangekündigt erscheinen oder ohne sich verabschieden zu gehen. Sehr gut, einander erzürnt den Rücken kehren. Ich weiß nicht, warum die Übersetzungen in dem ähnlich alten Deutschen geschrieben sind, aber ...
Da hat sie wahrscheinlich so ein altes Sprichwortbuch aus Preußen noch ausgegraben.
Genau, klingt ein bisschen so.
Und jetzt gibt es noch ein paar ohne Erklärung.
Er amüsiert sich wie ein Mops-Spitz im Rosengarten.
Okay, das erklärt sich von alleine.
Male im Speck.
Elefant im Porzellanladen, ihr versteht genau. Hund in der Pfanne. Genau. Am Anfang wollte ich hoch hinaus und kam nachher ins Gärtnerhaus. Was heißt das? Naja, deine Ambitionen haben nicht geklappt. Du hast enttäuscht. Aber sehr spezifisch die Erklärung, wenn jemand bei der Wahl einer Gattin anfänglich zu hohe Ansprüche und zuletzt arge Missgriffe macht. Auch Missgriffe. Wie viele Gattinnen-Missgriffe kann man denn in einem Leben machen? Oh, da frag mal jemanden die Kaffee. Wow! Ja, dem habe ich es jetzt gegeben, da hab ich jetzt nach oben getreten.
Sie hat auf die Angel gebissen, beziehungsweise sie ist befallen,
beziehungsweise sie ist schwer zu Fuss, beziehungsweise sie geht, tanzt, nicht mit sich allein,
beziehungsweise sie hat ein Quellkorn verschluckt, beziehungsweise sie ist ins Sommerfeld gesprungen,
beziehungsweise sie ist ins Sommerfeld gestrungen, beziehungsweise mit ihr ist's unrichtig, beziehungsweise sie ist verbubanzt. Wenn du zur Erklärung eines Sprichworten noch andere Fremdwörter benutzen wirst. Naja, halt sowas wie sie ist verbubanzt. Nee, wir sind von sie ist in Sommerfeld gesprungen. Ach so. Nee, mit ihr ist's unrichtig. Ich verstehe, mit ihr ist's unrichtig. Mit ihr ist es schlecht Sommerfeld. Ja genau, mit sie ist befallen. Ich verstehe, jetzt habe ich es verstanden. Aber weißt du, was es heißt? Sie ist tollpatschig. Nee, sie ist befallen. Sie ist schwer zu Fuss. Sie tanzt nicht mit sich allein. Sie tanzt nicht mit sich allein. Das finde ich eigentlich super. Nicht allein. Sie tanzt befallen. Nimm es mal sehr wörtlich. Sie tanzt nicht mit sich allein. Sie tanzt immer mit jemand anderem. Sie ist irgendwie unsteht, sie hat jede Nacht neun oder sowas. Oder sie ist leicht zu haben oder sowas. Sie tanzt nicht mit sich allein. Das kriegst du hin. Das musst du jetzt erraten. Sie tanzt nicht mit sich allein. Ja, und es ist wortwörtlich korrekt. Und es ist fantastisch. Ich finde diesen Spruch super. Sie tanzt nicht mit sich allein. Sie tanzt auf vielen Feten so, sie ist unstets, sie ändert ihre Meinung. Nee, sie tanzt wortwörtlich nicht mit sich allein, sie ist befallen, auch nicht schlecht, aber auch weird. Aber wenn sie nicht mit sich alleine tanzt, dann tanzt sie immer mit anderen Leuten. Nee, nicht immer mit anderen Leuten. Immer mit dem Gleichen? Mhm, sie tanzt nicht mit sich allein. Sie ist treu, sie ist loyal. Aber wenn man sie sehen würde, würde sie alleine tanzen, wenn man sie so sehen würde. Aber sie tanzt trotzdem ist noch eine Person. Ach so, sie ist breit. Sie verdeckt ihren Tanzpartner. Sie ist schwanger. Sie tanzt nicht mit sich allein. Okay. Okay. Vor Angst auf die Wand rennen. Das war der Letzte. Das heißt schwanger sein. Nein, nein, das ist auch noch eines. Das ist ein, unabhängig davon. Ja, also, verrückt. Sie ist befangen. Vielen Dank, dieser kleine Ausflug nach Good Old Preussen. Da war die Welt noch in Ordnung. Vielleicht sieht man sich ja noch. Die Alte ist befallen. Schwierig, ein paar waren schwierig, aber super. Also, vielen Dank, das ist super spannend, von 1865. Vielen Dank an Hollabeer oder Hollabeere von Reddit. Ja, vielen Dank an Reddit, da kommen immer tolle Sachen zusammen, postet da gerne, da kann alles gesammelt werden, ja, aber ich finde es interessant, wie die Sprache auch einfacher wird, also durch das Wegfallen von I, es wird immer einfacher so, also was ist das Limit, was ist die Minimalsprache, beschäftige mich. Englisch. Ja, Englisch, aber Englisch hat sich auch verändert. Also ich bin ja wieder mit Shakespeare befangen, aber da gab es ja früher auch im Englischen die Unterscheidung zwischen du und sie. Also heutzutage gibt es im Englischen nur noch you und früher gab es thou und you. Und thou war die umgangssprachliche Anrede, also das deutsche du und das you war das deutsche sie. Und irgendwann haben die gesagt, fuck it, wir lassen das thou weg, jetzt gibt es nur noch you. Fuck thou, wir nehmen das weg. Fuck thou. Und es gab auch unterschiedliche Verbformen, also du hast gesagt I speak, you speakest. Oder I want, you wantst. So wie im Deutschen, du willst. Aber es ist irgendwann rausgeflogen, dass man nur noch sagt I want, you want, so gleich. Das heißt, es wird immer einfacher. Wenn man über sich selber spricht, in der Vergangenheit habe ich auch schon mal gehört, dass man sagt, I says to him. Ja. Das ist auch interessant, ist auch verschwunden. Inzwischen ist ja nur noch he she ate, dass er es muss mit. Das ist das Einzige, ja. Aber früher gab es auch noch so ein I says to him, I says what is the Tao plan? Ja, es ist interessant, dass man im Umgangssprache dieses Tao immer so als hochgestochen Shakespearean benutzt, aber eigentlich heisst es Du, eigentlich ist es noch umgangssprachlicher als You. Also es ist eigentlich, wenn man jemanden hochheben will, dann sagt man vielleicht Thao und macht, aber es ist eigentlich genau andersrum. Ah, okay, also es ist nicht wie das Euch im Deutschen. Nee, eher das Du, es ist eigentlich noch vertrauter als das You. Im Deutschen ist es wirklich krass, dass es drei Varianten gibt, es gibt Duzzen, Sitzen und Irzen. Euchzen? Ja. Aber Euchzen ist Irzen, ne? Da habe ich mal eine Lehrerin geoutet, die nicht mit sich allein getanzt hat. Ja, ich glaube, ja. Ich habe vielleicht mal schon mal erzählt, aber da habe ich nämlich auch Spaß, jeden Tag, es war irgendwie Karneval oder sowas, einen Scherztag, ein lustiger Tag, wo alle sich verkleideten und in illustren Kostümen unterwegs waren. Ich war monarchisch unterwegs und hat er immer gesagt, alle immer geirzt. Dann habe ich auch Lehrerin geirzt und sie hat gesagt, weißt du das? Und ich so, was? Ja, dann sage ich so, ich bin schwanger. Weil sie dachte, ich spreche von ihr und dem Baby. Was natürlich furchtbar war, weil what the fuck, wie uncool, würde das mich machen, dass ich das anfange zu irzen, weil ich das Baby sofort als Teil von ihr wahrnehme und nicht als zwei verschiedene. Wie creepy wäre das, wenn man schwangere Frauen immer mit dem Plural ansprechen würde. Kommt ihr noch in die Küche? Und ich war so schockiert, auch immer ja, woher weißt du du das denn? Ja, okay, dann sag ich es jetzt halt. Ich bin schwanger, ich wollte es noch nicht sagen. Woher weißt du das denn? What the fuck? Ich laufe da nicht mit meinem Kostüm. Und aber hast du dann so diesen riesigen Hut abgenommen? Die große Krone habe ich abgenommen. Ich bin noch nicht bereit für den Thron. Ich bin zu unfleht.
Das tat mir so leid.
Ja, absolut. So leid, aber auch, wie sie gar nicht geschnallt hat.
Also wie kann man, dass sie mich so für unempathisch gehalten hat.
Ja gut, wenn das dein Geheimnis ist vielleicht so ein bisschen,
du denkst dir, Gott, die Schüler dürfen das nicht wissen.
Warum auch immer, aber keine Ahnung.
Wie geht's euch heute?
Woher weißt du das denn? Habt ihr die Klassenarbeit schon fertig korrigiert? Was war das für... Ich find das... Ich find's viel schlimmer, was sie... was sie denkt, wie... Ja. Unempanisch ich bin. Vor allem, dass... Also denkt sie, dass du extra dir dieses Outfit angezogen hast? Also, ja, wahrscheinlich ist es... Wenn man so in seiner eigenen Welt drin ist und man Angst davor hat, dass irgendwas rauskommt, dann denkt man nicht mehr logisch, sondern sieht nur noch überall Bedrohung, das kenne ich auch, aber ja, schwierig. Schwierig, ja genau, aber das finde ich mal, aber Frage an dich, Linguist, Linguist-Nerd. Ja. Gibt es eine dominante Sprache, glaubst du, es gibt eine dominante Sprache, eine Sprache, die sich natürlich umsetzen würde? So, jetzt sagen wir mal, wir nehmen, es gibt Achtlinge, es gibt Achtlinge identisch, mir geht's darum so, niemand ist intelligenter oder durchsetzungsstärker oder sowas oder hat finanziell mehr Power hinter sich. Alle Länder sind gleichwertig verteilt
und Sprachen haben nicht mit Ländern zu tun.
Die wachsen organisch, nicht organisch,
sondern in einem luftleeren Raum auf.
Und alle sprechen eine andere Sprache.
Sagen wir die meistgesprochenen Sprachen der Welt.
Wir denken uns alles weg.
Wir denken uns Wirtschaftsmacht weg.
Also die sind neu geboren, aber sprechen schon eine Sprache? Ja, nur für das Gedanken-Experiment. Nur, dass man alles weglöscht aus dem Kopf, was so etwas wie Wirtschaftsstärke, Population oder so was ist. Die sprechen alle, der eine spricht Englisch, der andere Mandarinen, da gibt es jemanden, der spricht Deutsch. Was auch immer, verstehst du schon. Acht Sprachen, die du jetzt... Acht fiktive Sprachen. Du kennst acht Sprachen, wir müssen jetzt nicht da durchgehen, dass du jetzt acht Sprachen. So, welche Sprache würdest du sagen, setzt dich dadurch? Ja, das ist eine interessante Frage. Ich glaube, es würde sich wahrscheinlich vermischen irgendwie so, dass man sagt, du hast das coolste Wort dafür oder so. Aber schwierig, ich meine... Grammatikalisch, man muss sich ja auch grammatikalisch auf das einigen.
Ja, oft, ja, ich weiß nicht,
oft ist es ja wahrscheinlich irgendwie
gewaltsam, dass irgendwo Land
eingenommen wird oder man entscheidet sich.
Ich glaube, in den USA war es ja auch knapp davor,
deutsch zu werden, so die USA-Sprache,
wodurch dann jetzt wahrscheinlich die Weltsprache deutsch
gewesen wäre. Verdammt!
Aber Englisch ist natürlich schon ein bisschen merkwürdig, weil
verhältnismässig sprechen ja wenig Menschen Englisch als Muttersprache, gemessen an der Weltpopulation. Richtig? Warum ist das eine Sprache, die sich so rückt? Wegen Shakespeare! Weil Shakespeare so viele Worte erfunden hat. Aber ist es neben Wirtschaftspower und so einem Shit vielleicht auch einfach, weil es eine sehr einfache Sprache ist? Kann schon sein, ist schon sehr einfach, ja. Keine dummen Artikel, so stimmt schon, ja, vielleicht hat man das immer weiter weggeschliffen. Genau, also vielleicht ist es einfach eine einfache Sprache, die man gut auch lernen kann, wenn man nicht guter Sprachler ist, und deswegen wird es sich immer weiter durchsetzen? Kann schon sein, die einfachste Sprache setzt sich durch, finde ich gut. Finde ich auch gut, weil Menschen faul sind und es ist ein einfaches Betriebssystem. Faul und das kann man einfach lernen und deuten. Aber, und das fand ich auch ganz spannend, noch mal ein letztes Mal zurück zu Shakespeare, weil ich finde immer, die interessanten Sachen sind die Dinge, die verloren gegangen sind, wie mit den Sprichwörtern zum Beispiel. Und es gibt in Shakespeare, gibt es ein Wort, das niemand versteht. Niemand weiss, was dieses Wort bedeutet. Es gibt ein einziges Theaterstück, Measure for Measure, da kommt das Wort zweimal vor, kurz hintereinander, aber niemand weiss, was dieses Wort bedeutet. Aber man hat es damals verstanden? Vielleicht, vielleicht. Es gibt Briefe, Briefwechsel nach dieser Aufführung. Dieses Wort taucht nirgendwo auf, in keinem Schriftstück, aus keiner Zeit. Niemand hat irgendeine Referenz für dieses Wort, niemand weiss, was es bedeutet. Und bis heute steht halt in den Begleittexten immer, keine Ahnung, wenn du den Text übersetzen musst, musst du h. Das Wort, auch nach dem Sprachen. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Wahnsinn. Und das Wort ist Prenzy. Prenzy. Prenzy. Und niemand weiss, was es bedeutet. Und es gibt einmal so diese Stelle, wo irgendjemand was sagt über eine andere Figur und dann antwortet der andere so, The Prenzy Angelo? Und man sagt so, hm? Und niemand... Auch die Figur so. Der andere Figur so. Excuse me? Was? Excuse me? Excuse me. Aber bis heute weiß niemand, was es bedeutet. Es gibt die Theorie, dass es ein Schreibfehler ist, dass es vielleicht Precise heisst oder Princely oder eine Mischung aus Frenzy, Princcely oder sowas, aber es weiß einfach niemand.
Aber geschrieben wie frenzy?
P-R-I-N-Z-I-E.
Nicht ganz wie, mit I-E am Ende,
nicht ganz wie frenzy, aber
also wenn ihr richtig
abgehoben klingen wollt und eure
Königsfigur wirklich authentisch spielen möchtet,
dann benutzt Prenzy.
Prenzy, ich habe mal gegoogelt, ich bin jetzt beim Collinsdictionary.com. Prenzy in British English, Prenzy, Adjektiv. A word used by Shakespeare, possibly a mistake. Supposed by some to mean precise. Ja. Supergeil, dann hast du es geschafft. Schon, ne? Also jetzt, ich muss sagen, Shakespeare hat es geschafft. Jetzt kommt der Verschlag. Das ist der Moment, wo ich denke, krass, der Typ hat es geschafft, der Dude, he made it, er hat es geschafft. He did it. My boy! My boy Shakespeare war da beim Collinsdictionary.com, steht da jetzt. Und das ist einfach mehr geil. Possibly mistake. Er ist auch gut, er ist fantastisch. Aber das Tolle ist, dass... Häufigkeit eins von fünf. Ja. Wahrscheinlich das seltenste, vielleicht ist es wirklich das seltenste Wort der Welt, weil es wirklich nur zweimal vorkommt und danach wird es nur zitiert. Es kommt nur zweimal vor und direkt hintereinander. Deswegen denkt man, vielleicht ist es kein Schreibfehler
oder man hat einfach den Schreibfehler noch mal kopiert.
Man weiß es einfach nicht. Also es ist einfach
unklar.
Glaubst du, man kann irgendwann so sehr
quasi alle Texte in der KI, weil es gibt
jetzt schon eine Website,
da kannst du ein Buch eingeben
und diese Website kennt dann das
Buch, weil da sind irgendwie die ganzen Kindle-Datenbanken
oder so ist da drin und dieses Buch, also es ist eine KI, die sich nur stützt auf dieses eine Buch. Und du kannst dann dem Buch Fragen stellen. Und es antwortet aus Sicht des Buches, beantwortet ihr. Wer ist der Vater von Luke Skywalker? Ja, das könnte die Star Wars-Novelle sehr gut verraten. Aber zum Beispiel auch, das hat dann ein Kollege mir geschickt,
dieses Drehbuchbuch Save the Cat,
wo sehr vereinfacht die Heldenreise und wie Filme aufgebaut sind,
erklärt wird, was ein supercooler Einstieg eigentlich damals auch für mich war.
Ich glaube, super Standardwerk für alle.
Umso mal einfacher hat es sich.
Warum hast du denn alle Regeln ignoriert?
Weil man nur wirklich Kunst macht, wenn man seinen eigenen Weg geht, auch die Regeln gebricht und weil Netflix einfach auch doofe Anmerkungen hat. Und das war voll geil, weil dann kann man dem Buch Fragen stellen. Das heißt, das ist ein grattes Buch, weil man das auch sehr gut versteht, aber es gibt ja auch dicke Schinken, wo man gerne darauf zugreifen würde.
Also anstatt einem Hörbuch machst du ein Interview mit dem Buch.
Also du fütterst diese KI, schliesst die KI dann irgendwie an so einen Sprachgenerator an und sagst dann irgendwie Mr. Bible, let's talk.
Okay, hi.
Thanks for the invitation. No, it's fine, it's fine. Thanks for taking the time, you must be a very busy book. Of course. I am, actually. Why did... But I'm humble about it, I'm humble about it. No, that's okay. That's one of my lessons, be humble. Really? I don't know, I think so. Why did all those people had to die in the big flood? Why did they have to die? That's an excellent question, first of all, Mr. King. Thanks so much for this question. Well, let me answer this question by saying that, would you even think about this part of the book when like three people died, when like four people died. It was just attention grabbing. It's a bit, it's a question of scale and gravitas of some sort. And well, it's an excellent question and I'm happy to make that point clear. You sound a little bit like you don't know the answer really. I can't explain everything that's written inside of me because it's more like it's keeping the mystery alive and it's more that's one of my key phrases it's about believing not knowing. What's with the title Bible, how did you come up with that word? Why was that so important to you? When I was on Tenerife for two weeks, I came across this little stone and I thought, Bible is ... You were the book, so you were the book, you were on vacation? Yes, my companion,, he had me in his back and he took me to Tenerife. Who was it? It's a guy called Clark from the UK. Okay. He brought me along and I saw the stone and I thought, Bible, it's an excellent title. Was there something written on the stone? No, just a regular old stone, and I thought maybe Bible is the perfect title for me. It's a good title, I don't know. I think so too. But is there a meaning behind the title? Is it just ... No, it's just like the word. Do I say it right, Bibel? It's like Thales, you know, Thales. Thales, what's that? It's a train that connects Cologne.
I see.
Maybe with Paris or for example Brussels.
You spend a lot of time in Cologne, don't you?
Yes.
Why?
Listen, this artificial intelligence might not be that great.
I'm not that great.
Are you so humble?
You're so humble.
Just believe, believe it works. All right. But it doesn't work. Just one last question. Jesus dies three days later. Spoiler alert. Yeah, I think we've all seen the movie. Three days later, he pops out of the grave again. Why? Why isn't he dead? Why can't he stay dead just like everybody else else? He can stay dead to prove the point, which is belief, belief in God, belief in the Almighty above us all, and he's able to bring you back. And what happened then, Hino? Then he's just around, he sticks around. He's just around? He's just around, drinking beer. Having what? No, no, just say that. Having what? Beer. Some beers. Just beer? Just beers and wines. Okay. So where is he now? Goddard wines. He's around. He's around? I think he might be on Tenerife. We don't know. Alright. He might be around. Thanks a lot, Mr. Bible. Thanks. Very insightful conversation. No, thank you. thanks a lot. And now es funktioniert noch nicht so gut. Es könnte ein guter Podcast werden, glaube ich. Also man interviewt. Es funktioniert noch nicht. Aber und die Fragen, die man stellt, sind alles durchlich. Ich bin noch ein bisschen enttäuscht von der ganzen KI. Ja, dein KI ist schon wieder durch, oder was für dich? Ich bin enttäuscht, bin enttäuscht. Ja, wir haben ja letztens empfohlen, der Twitch-Kanal Seinfeld, Nothing Forever, Nothing Forever, wurde jetzt offline genommen. Ah ja. Wegen Widerstoss, Widerverstoss gegen die Nutzungsbedingungen von Twitch, was auch immer, offline. Ui. Also, doch nicht ganz forever. Weil Twitch gesagt hat, gemerkt hat, es ist zu lustig. Too much fun. Too much fun. Too much fun for my taste. Nothing forever. This is twitch.com. This isn't YouTube. This isn't Pornhub. This is Twitch. Alright? We want to celebrate entertainment with a distinct taste. Ja, okay, die Website, wo leicht bekleidete Frauen in Whirlpools streamen und man das dann guckt man dann während des Contents. We have a lot of literature shows. Literature shows. Yes, yes, indeed. Ich glaube, es spielen alle nur CSGO, haben die 88 im Gesicht tätowiert und fangen an. A superficial look like yours may come to that conclusion indeed, but not if you look beneath it. Ich meine, ich finde es sehr merkwürdig. So habe ich mir die Webseite nicht vorgestellt. Sie sind gut gekleidete Brite mit einem Gehstock, einem Monokel. Danke, mein liebes Freund und Freund. Lassen Sie mich sagen, ihr Anzug ist fantastisch. Oh, danke. Massgeschneidert sieht man, ist ganz, ganz toll. Er ist in meiner Familie für ein lang, langer Zeit. Die Twitch-Famil long, long time. The Twitch family. Yes, the Twitch family indeed. Okay. The Duke of Twitch in the late 19th century first created the idea of an endless stream of entertainment that you can just plug in and enjoy. Aber Seinfeld ist doch jetzt nicht ... Ich sag mir das Niveau, wo ich so was zerlieb. No, no, no, it's raunchy, it's nasty, I don't want to have it on my site. No, no, no, no, we're gonna watch them theater now. Okay, also die Hot Tub Girls. The form of the human female can be somewhat pleasurable indeed. Sie sind alter, perverser Freak. No, no, no, get out, get out of my website. Use are a freak. No. I bid you to leave right now. Das finde ich eine gute Idee, dass man Webseitenfragen stellen kann. Ja, das finde ich auch gut. Ich meine, ja, Google, ja. Aber auch mal andere Fragen. Also, wie wäre eine andere Website als Suchmaschine? Weswegen ich drauf kam, ist nämlich meine Frage, kann man nicht irgendwann alles, was Shakespeare geschrieben hat, in die KI packen und dann sagt die einem genau, was das Wort bedeutet und oder ob das nicht, ob das nicht, ob das ein Fehler war.
Gute Frage, hausgabe für alle Programmierer. I'm misspelled, I'm sorry, I'm such an idiot. Ja, aber man muss auch sagen, also kurzer nochmal, ein letztes Mal zu Shakespeare, weil das ursprüngliche Werk ist ja das Folio. Das ist ja dieses dicke Buch, das sechs Jahre nach Shakespeare's Tod veröffentlicht wurde, wo die meisten seiner Stücke abgedruckt wurden. Was damals gar nicht gängig war, dass Theaterstücke abgedruckt wurden. Aber mehr dazu in der nächsten Folge. Mehr dazu in meinem Podcast. The Immortal Bard. Und ja, es gibt wahrscheinlich kein Buch der Welt, das so intensiv analysiert wurde wie dieses. Und die Shakespeare-Forscher haben auch Unterschiede. Weil ich, wenn man so eine, keine Ahnung, ein Diktat geschrieben, dann gibt man das ab vorne und ein Lehrer liest das und man denkt so, oh Gott, oh Gott, liest sich alles durch, oh Gott, oh Gott, habe ich keinen Quatsch geschrieben. Und genau so stelle ich mir vor, wie ein Shakespeare schreibt was und die gibt's ab und die ganze Welt analysiert das. Die Jahrhunderte danach. Fuck, fuck, fuck, shit, shit, shit, shit. Und nicht nur Shakespeare analysiert, sondern man hat sich Gedanken gemacht, wie viele Setzer haben an diesem Buch gearbeitet. Weil du hast so eine große Druckerpresse, Presse, Brezel, eine große Druckerpretzel und dann setzt du... Eine große Drucker-Prenzy. und dann setzt du so die Buchstaben und dann druckst du es. Und dann haben die versucht, verschiedene Setzer zu analysieren. Aber haben die teilweise auch nochmal, aha, weil derjenige hat es hier messed up, basically. Genau, und die haben nämlich Setzer und dann haben sie durch ihre geniale Shakespeare-Forschung herausgefunden, dass fünf Leute haben am Satz dieses Buchs gearbeitet. dann hat sie... Kommen Sie mit erhobenen Händen raus!
Kommen Sie raus!
Was, was, was? Wir sind nur Setzer!
Ganz langsam, Hände auf dem Kopf, ganz langsam.
Sie waren einer von den fünf Setzern,
die damals bei Shakespeare mitgemacht haben.
Hände auf dem Kopf!
Wir haben ihre Familie, wir haben ihre Tochter,
wir haben ihre andere Tochter
und wir haben ihre Frau.
Okay.
So, Sie
sagen uns jetzt, ob Sie
an dem Wort Prenzzi beteiligt waren oder nicht.
Nein. Sonst bringen wir sie um, nacheinander.
Okay? Prenzzi, ja.
Warnschuss, Warnschuss. Okay, ich habe nur
Romeo und Julia gemacht. Ich habe nur, sorry,
ich habe nur Romeo und Julia gemacht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Measure for Measure, ich weiss nicht mehr, worum sie
hat Measure for Measure übersetzt.
Nicht übersetzt, gesetzt.
Hören Sie! Ringen Sie! Es war Robert! Also alle Einheiten auf Robert. Robert Jameson. Robert Jameson. Helikopter dreht ab. Aber Robert ist bis heute auf der Flucht. Und die haben diese fünf Sätze nach Kompetenz geordnet. Oh mein Gott. Diese Shakespeare-Forscher, Indian-Tweets-Jakets, haben diese fünf Sätze nach Kompetenz geordnet. Und sie haben ihn wie nach Erfahrung, persönliche Likeability, nach dem wie viele Fehler sie beim Setzen gemacht haben, wie genau die Buchstaben beieinander sind, die Abstände, wie viele Fehler, wie viele Rechtschreibfehler und sowas. Und sie haben sie geordnet und es gibt Sätze A, makellos, kein einziger Fehler, Sätze B, ein einziger Fehler bei Hunderttausenden von Verszahlen. Ich weiß, dass ich meinen Job gut kann, ich will trotzdem nicht bewertet werden von Ihnen. Ich bewerte Sie ja auch nicht, was ist überhaupt Ihr Job? Naja, Sie sind schon seit 500 Jahren tot. Wie nervig dann so bewertet zu werden von Randos. Setzer C, hier und da mal leichte Fehler, alles in allem aber sehr gut. Zwei Min. Zwei minus, Setzer D, manchmal ganze Wörter verhauen. Und dann kommen wir zu Setzer E. Setzer E weist die maximale Inkompetenz auf. Ihr Sohn weist die maximale Inkompetenz. Ich bitte? Ist du mir leid, sei leid. Die maximale... Ich weiss, es ist nicht üblich, dass man Eltern reinbestellt, ist nicht üblich bei einem Job. Aber ihr Sohn ist ja auch schon weit über 40. Alles in Ordnung mit Robert. Deswegen habe ich sie bestellt per Telegram. Wir sind ja gerade an den Werken von Shakespeare. Hat er Freunde in der Firma? Den kennt man noch nicht. Ich lese selbst keine Bücher. Ich ich kann selbst gar nicht lesen. Ich weiß, ich habe gar kein Problem. Wir sind so stolz auf Robert, dass er, also er war nie gut in der Schule, aber wir haben ihm die Schule bezahlen können. Es ist nur so, dass Robert mit, also wir haben unsere Sätze sortiert nach Skills und er ist der mit Abstand schlechteste. Ist manchmal komplett alles verhauen. Also wirklich Wörter komplett verhauen. Wir wollten fragen, ist zu Hause alles gut, oder können Sie da irgendwie darauf achten, dass Sie ich weiß nicht, dass er zu Hause genug Ausgleich bekommt, oder wir machen uns ein bisschen Sorgen um Robert. Er war eigentlich immer so ein Prenzy-Junge. Aber so ein Prenzy-Junge, also wir hatten so eine Prenzy-Zeit, eine ganze Kindheit war Prenzy. Was für eine Zeit? Prenzy. Moment mal. Haltet die Druckerpresse an! Stopp! Die Eltern haben die Mütter dabei gemacht, die es nicht gibt. Aber es ist auch für mich fantastisch. Vor 500 Jahren haben irgendwie fünf Leute an einem Nachmittag dieses Buch gesetzt. Und jetzt werden sie einfach gedemütigt für den Rest ihres Lebens. Dafür, dass sie so viele Fehler gemacht haben. Das heißt, es könnte auch sein, dass es ein Fehler ist, Prenzy. Aber, aber, aber, man weiß ja dann, also wenn die die alle sortierten konnten, wissen sie ja, wer welchen Part gemacht hat. Und war der mit Prenzy? Das weiß ich leider nicht. Das ist leider das unbefriedigende Detail, das ich jetzt nicht liefern kann. Das ist so doof, weil das müsste man ja sofort hinkriegen. Weil die wissen ja genau, welcher Part von wem kommt. Genau. Und dann könnten sie ja eigentlich sagen, Apprensic kann man von A, das heißt, es war definitiv kein Fehler. Ja. Oder A konnte einfach nur sehr gut setzen, aber es hat keine... Es kann natürlich auch ein Fehler im Quellmaterial sein, die haben das ja abgeschrieben von so Textzeiten. Aber dann fragst du doch in der Druckerpresse mal nach. Sorry, das ist ein Wort, der gibt gar kein Sinn. Bei Shakespeare, der über tausend Phrasen erfunden hat, he's in a pickle. Ruf ihn nochmal an. Du,
William. Ich finde gut, dass du genau da bist, wo du am Anfang
des Podcasts warst. Ich glaube, in der zweiten
Folge oder sowas hast du diese Pickle-Scheule.
Genau, ja, Pickle, ja. Und jetzt geht alles full circle.
Du bist wieder da.
Hast du so ein, wie lange hast du jetzt? Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt einen Zyklus
abgeschlossen. Sieben Jahre? Sieben Jahre sagt man ja.
Zyklus abgeschlossen, aber
wir wissen, der nächste Zyklus beginnt, und zwar schon nächste Woche. Und ich freue mich auf euch, haut rein, habt eine schöne Woche. Wir sehen uns dann wieder. Stefan? Wünsche ich euch auch. Nee, müsste ich euch auch ganz herzlich wünschen. Klang jetzt nicht so ehrlich. Doch, heute war ein bisschen melancholisch. Du hast heute ein bisschen niedergeschlagen, habe ich das Gefühl. Man hat manchmal Tage, wo es einem nicht so gut geht. Das ist völlig okay, auch wenn ihr da draußen immer so Tage habt.
Hoffentlich konnten wir euch ein bisschen
aus diesem dunklen Zerren ins Licht führen. Alles klar, wir heben ab, macht's gut, bis nächste Woche, ciao! The Worst Bird Production. Und nächste Woche bei Das Podcast UFO. Hey, erinnert ihr euch noch an Pluto, den neunten und aussenstehendsten Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem und das macht er heute? Aber uns ist beiden schon lange nichts mehr Witziges passiert, das muss man wirklich auch mal sagen. Jemand lässt das Fenster runter, ab wann fängt man an zu sprechen? Und er hat, das ist sehr gemein, dass ich diese Story erzähle, aber ich weiß nicht, was sie damit meinen. Du bist neben meiner Familie die beständigste Person in meinem Leben. Hatte die erste Autofabrik Parkplätze.
Willst du mich jetzt auch umbringen? Wollen wir uns jetzt auch?
Okay, ich fordere dich, mein Sohn, zum Duell!